and just like that september's passed us
by if there's anything i can take away
from this season is the fact that it's
being quite action-packed this season
gave us a number of action series and
with them came some amazing fights so
here are some of my favorite fights of
the season let's go
[Music]
let's just say that star wars has had
quite a tumultuous run in recent years i
wouldn't say that the franchise is
marred with controversy per se but the
last few movies have been quite
polarizing now haven't they well the
newest chapter to the saga and anime out
of all things seems to set things up to
an upswing star wars visions has debuted
to a very positive response and it has a
lot to do with how each episodic chapter
carries some interesting story potential
among those the ninth jedi is my
favorite one by far it really captures
the classic star wars field the most
amongst the episodes and i wouldn't
really mind it being a launch pad into
an entirely new series oh and there's
that amazing fight with sith vs jedi's i
love it simply for the high speed
frantically choreographed action i've
come to love the franchise for in a
little over just a minute it also
showcased some of the best of star wars
battles you have the quick one shot the
usage of force powers and lightning and
the very fast-paced dances that are the
lightsaber battles a lot of people
consider this episode the best one in
the series and it's not hard to see why
[Music]
at times first impressions are
everything that's all you need to get a
legion of anime fans following your show
weekly if you're asking me for the best
first impression of the season i'd
easily give it to the detective is
already dead things opened with a bang
in the show's pilot episode featuring an
amazingly animated fight between siesta
and komori everyone was raving about
this fight and its animation but in
terms of narrative placement i also like
it very much it gives us a glimpse of
what to expect out of the show and that
it's a mystery show with a healthy
amount of fighting and dashes of
supernatural it's a blend of genres that
the show prides itself on and while it
may seem that the anime team blew their
effort and budget in the first episode
of the show i'd say this fight allowed
the show to get off on the right foot
we proceed with luffy versus ulti kaiser
on route to its landmark one thousandth
episode one piece gave us a treat with a
recent fight altis no slouch and despite
the hype that luffy gets with his
newfound powers aldi still puts up a
fight that has him on the ropes punches
were thrown haki's clashing it's
definitely not as high for some of the
major boss fights in one piece history
but we're talking over two decades of
anime here the fight is still pretty
damn good as a standalone always love
seeing luffy in action and i say that he
really works well in these short but
sweet jewels and of course yamato's
entrance at the end i feel like toei
absolutely nailed the thunder bhagwa
scene
[Music]
next on the list is kaneme versus mobu
why is everyone sleeping on kingdom
again why when it's got spectacular
action and intense battles like this one
i know the show has had its share of
fans but i feel that it's always this
underappreciated show that deserves a
lot more fans perhaps the whole dynasty
warrior setting is quite niche just like
sengoku basara during its heyday the
kingdom is much more than that we expect
a lot of army battles in something like
this but the fight that stole the show
for me is ghanme vs mobile from the
current season standing ahead of their
respective armies the two combatants
engage each other on horseback not
giving anything to the other i just love
the intensity in this fight there's not
much visual eye candy that we've been
spoiled with thanks to ufo table and
mappa but the fight more than makes it
up with intensity and the level of
gravity thanks to the music and the slow
panning shots it's just one of those
gritty tense battles that can even stand
to be a bit bloodier to drive the point
home
speaking of ensemble fights domain vs
valhalla is really epic
yep this is something that i'd expect
from tokyo revenge's good old gang wars
that have no shortage of fierce action
and drama the fights between the mob are
all sorts of intense but the camera's
all focused on the meat of the action i
really find the camera cuts in their
individual fights so well done you can
feel that you're part of the action by
just watching and seeing how each of
their fast blows gets captured in anime
forms but it was mikey scene that stole
the show for me the tension and the
drama was an all-time high and it looks
like one of dorman's pillars finally bit
the dust until he didn't i got
goosebumps seeing mikey get back up and
hand everyone else a whole can of ass
kicking he's down but he's never out and
all it takes is a switch being flipped
for him to go all bad ass and raise hell
all over the enemies
rin versus nickel from either then
deities is also pretty cool
at first i wasn't too sure what to
expect from this late coming to the
season the premise is simple enough but
i didn't think that either then dt's had
a premise that lends itself to a lot of
attention grabbing battles the synopsis
partially thanks to the art reads more
like a comedy with a few dashes of nice
fights nice but pretty standard and not
too great i'm glad to have been proven
wrong though especially with this fight
between rin and nickel or should i say
rin's showcase of power the fight looks
unique compared to the rest of the
roster so fighting that it retains the
light cartoony appeal of ida den deity's
art it doesn't look as crisp or modern
as something like the siesta fight that
started this list regardless the fight
has that same appeal that those chinese
anime fights that i love so much had in
that despite the simplistic art style
it's got that wacky cartoony feel that
you might just enjoy
[Music]
it feels so good to have madoka magika
once again the new movie looms in the
horizon and the second half of magyar
record finally kicks the plot into
overdrive after what the first season
left us in particular i really loved
seeing our favorite magical girls in
action again and margie our record does
an excellent job of introducing new
characters and having them work with or
face off against the legacy characters i
always felt that mommy would have been a
great villain and she displays that
pedigree in full glory in this fight
against everyone her bullet hell
abilities always steal the show and
fighting without restraint as a villain
it becomes even more of a treat to watch
suruno has her own issues with the
protagonists and it's nice to see the
two groups of battles converge into one
chaotic display of explosions and magic
the fight also has quite the emotional
backdrop to it and while margie a record
may not have quite captured the success
of its predecessor this season 2 has
more than redeemed season 1 for me
there's a lot more at stake and far
better action
a featured castlevania fight often in
these videos so i think that the witcher
deserves a mention too
[Music]
it's not anime in the traditional sense
but the anime version of the witcher has
had some highlights of its own one such
highlight is chetra vs vesamir while i
won't say that the fight carries the
entire movie and makes it an absolute
must-watch it's also an absolute treat
that shows off what non-japan animation
can do fans also agree that jetra is one
of the great antagonists in this list
that greatly expands the lore of the
games this fight really sold me to her
as a character and it felt so good
seeing the two combatants go back and
forth inside the crammed space amidst
the fires the witch anime is good
supplementary material to the game and
the tv show so if you are a fan make
sure to check it out the movie still is
pretty good in its own right so that's
probably a point of consideration for
you too
my hero academia continues rolling with
shigeraki vs redestro
my villain academia hitting all the
right notes in the decisive
confrontation between the two leaders of
the villainous factions a lot of people
have been clamoring to see shigaraki and
redestro duking it out in anime form and
while that fight's been toned down it
still does manage to be a home run
villain versus villain showdowns have
always been interesting because it's a
battle that you can sit back and not be
too invested on one side or it should
have been what happens is that a lot of
these end up having one less bad guy for
you to root for in this case i found
myself rooting for shigaraki more due to
how much better he is as a character for
me but none of that matters when we
start seeing the fireworks flight and
the city being destroyed in a clash that
would put some of the previous mha
battles to shame with two characters who
have less of a moral compass duking it
out you'd expect to see carnage and
destruction and that's exactly what we
got in the end shigeraki stands
victorious after leaving a lot of
annihilation in his wake capping off the
ark that ended up being a lot more
interesting than i first expected it to
be when it was still in its anime form
should i also point out that both of
their powers show some similarities to
deku's and overhauls powers talk about
irony and a callback to one of the best
fights of the previous my hero academia
him
you think that these slice of life
dragons can throw it down but here we
are doru and elmar just had an intense
battle that could give some shonen
fights a run for their money thoru and
elma blast each other with attacks that
just make you go wow seeing each blast
that sends the combatants flying miles
away is a joy but i love the banter more
in-fight talking helps drives up the
stakes and the intensity of a fight and
the voice actors show us a better way
than expected example of that here it
also gave us a surprisingly touching
scene between the combatants which i
feel is the more important takeaway here
fights are not just all about the energy
blasts and the punches after all the
emotion has to be there as well on the
meta side of things what makes this
sequence so touching is that it's
something created in-house in kyoto
animation the whole sequence is the
staff flexing their skills and
delivering with a product that's a lot
better than what we can ask for shows a
lot about the resiliency of one of the
best studios in the industry all things
considered in spite of the tragedy a few
years ago kyoto animation has come back
stronger and i find that a very
wholesome thing
coming up next is naruto vs ishiki
[Applause]
ishiki's been having naruto's number for
the longest time he already did the
unthinkable and beat both naruto and
sasuke and he looks to be in the process
of doing so again this time naruto has a
new form but will it be able to turn the
tides we're talking about a new form in
shonen anime so what do you expect new
forms may not win all the time but they
sure look good doing so almost all the
time barry on mode ends up being
impressive with it all allowing naruto
to bring the beat down to ishiki
smacking him around and drawing lots of
clean hits that would have taken out any
lesser being all while looking all kinds
of sleek thanks to the huge makeover it
doesn't come without a price though as
both he and ishiki will soon realize as
the battle wears on this entry is a late
edition that came up as i was in the
process of wrapping up the video script
but it's very worth the spot you can
really feel the impact from each of
naruto's blows and with the rocky music
keeping you pumped up the battle is a
treat to watch hand-to-hand combat has
rarely looked this good but the guys
behind boruto did it the adaptation
really did justice to the hype
so how would you rank these 10 fights
though i'm curious to see which one
you'd put on top of a hypothetical list
if you had a great time and one more
don't forget to check out the channel
for the past videos that you may have
missed after checking those out you can
head over to the members only videos and
consider applying for channel membership
my patreon is also in the description
box in case you really want to help me
make more amazing videos and your help
would be one of the best things i could
possibly get that's it for today's list
i hope to see you again next time and
i'll be back with more anime countdowns
see ya
[Music]
you